SELF OFFING RATE:
Since 2000, the self offing rate in the United
States has increased by 50% from 11 per 100,000
people to 16 per 100,000 people. Many would blame
modern tech for much of this increase. People are
more glued to their phones and computers than ever
before leading to less human interactions and more
isolation resulting in high levels of depression
and thus more self offings. Now, that could very
well be a factor but something that has a much
more concrete connection is a medication
called Fluoxetine or Prozac. Prozac is a
medication that is supposed to treat depression,
OCD, panic disorders, and bulimia. Theoretically,
it is supposed to accomplish this by increasing
Serotonin levels inside the brain which seem to
have a positive correlation with mood, emotion,
and sleep. Today, Prozac is the 25th most
prescribed medication with an estimated 23 million
patients within the US alone. So, at first glance,
Prozac seems like a miracle medication that has
helped hundreds of millions of people overcome
the darkest part of their lives. But, what if I
told you that Prozac was actually doing the exact
opposite? You see, while Prozac may be successful
at giving patients a surge of joy or excitement,
over the long term, it can actually make
patients more likely to end it all. Surely,
such a severe side effect was an unintended
consequence and something that Eli Lilly,
the creators of Prozac, simply didn’t discover
during their initial studies. Well actually,
there’s reports from the British Medical Journal
suggesting that Eli Lilly not only knew about
these side effects but that they went as far
as concealing the evidence that was suggesting
this. One of their own studies found that 38%
of patients taking Prozac displayed symptoms
of agitation and aggression while only 19% of
patients taking the placedo displayed the same
symptoms. And this was way back in 1988 but here’s
the catch. Eli Lilly allegedly never handed over
these findings to the FDA clinical reviewer who
was responsible for approving the medication. Now,
this could’ve been an honest mistake but when
coincidence aligns with opportunity, that’s rarely
the case. Not to mention, this is just one of Eli
Lilly’s many allegations and settlements. But,
despite this shady history, Eli Lilly is not only
doing well, they’re doing phenomenal. In fact,
their stock is up 5X within the past 5 years alone
which has given them a market cap of just over
$400 billion. At this point, they’re often trading
spots with J&J for the title of world’s largest
pharmaceutical company. So, here’s how Eli Lilly
managed to make $400 billion worth of blood money.
ELI LILLY:
Taking a look back, the story of Eli Lilly dates
back to the late 1800s to a man named Eli Lilly.
Eli was a Civil War veteran having served as a
colonel during the war. And he wanted to transfer
the altruistic ambitions of the Civil War into a
company of his own, only instead of fighting
slavery, he would be fighting disease. And
with that, Eli would open up a small laboratory in
Indianapolis in 1876. Eli wasn’t creating anything
ground breaking per se. He was simply producing
and selling medications that were already on the
market. But, thanks to his war legacy and a lack
of big pharma, it didn’t take Eli very long to
get the people of Indianapolis behind him. One
of the first medicines that Eli sold was Quinine
which is used to treat Malaria. This alone
allowed him to reach sales of of over $4000 by
the end of the first year alone. That’s over a
$120,000 today. Within just 3 years though, he
would over 10X that amount growing to $49,000
in sales or over $1.3 million today. All of
this extra revenue gave Eli plenty of headroom
to expand and invest back into the business,
and that’s exactly what he would do. In 1878, Eli
would hire his brother James as his first full
time salesman, and James would start marketing
their products across the nation. Back at home,
Eli was also investing heavily into research and
development. One of their first inventions was
adding fruity flavors and sugar to their pills
which made them much more palatable and far
more popular. As their medicines gained popularity
across the nation, Eli would go ahead and formally
incorporate the company in 1881 and this marked
the beginning of Eli Lilly’s monumental rise.
Within the next 20 years, Eli Lilly would grow
to over 2000 product lines, more than $300,000
in annual sales, and nationwide relevance but
Eli never let this success get to his head.
He strongly believed that the industry needed
ethical reform. That miracle medicine needed to be
replaced by medications that had strong scientific
backgrounds and mountains of evidence. These are
the only types of medication that Eli carried up
until his death in 1898 and his son, Josiah, would
uphold this legacy after he took over. During the
early 1900s, Eli Lilly would became masters of
manufacturing which was really the secret behind
their extraordinary reach and scale. In fact,
Eli Lilly was so good at manufacturing that they
would often have excess capacity that they would
sell off to their competitors. By 1917, they were
operating the largest capsule factory in the world
producing more than 2.5 million capsules
per day. But with Eli’s son at the helm,
it seems that this success did get to his head
as it wasn’t long until we saw the first inklings
of monopolistic anti consumer practices. And
this had to do with none other than Insulin.
SHAKY FUNDAMENTALS:
In 1921, three scientists from the Univeristy
of Toronto began working on a treatment for
diabetes which was at the time deadly. These guys
would end up developing a commercially producible
insulin which ended up winning them a nobel prize.
Eli Lilly was watching all this unfold from the
sidelines and they were extremely interested
in the project from the very beginning. But,
to their disappointment, the researchers were
extremely hesitant in regards to working with a
commercial firm. They had much more altruistic
motives and were more concerned about insulin
helping people as opposed to generating a
profit. But, despite this, the researchers
would eventually team up with Eli Lilly when the
realized that this was the only way to reach the
scale the dreamed of. And with that, Eli Lilly
began selling insulin in 1923 and they’ve had a
monopoly over insulin eversince. In fact, to this
day, Eli Lilly, Sanofi, and Novo Nordisk control
90% of the US insulin market. For the first time,
Eli Lilly had a medication that people would buy
regardless of their financial situation and this
would quickly show during the Great Depression.
While people were losing their life savings,
companies were going bankrupt, and investors
were losing millions, Eli Lilly would actually
reach record high sales of $13 million in 1932.
That’s the same as $287 million today. As you
can see, with insulin, Eli Lilly was starting to
veer off from their altruistic roots but they had
yet to turn to the darkside completely. In fact,
throughout the next few decades, they would
be involved in a few commendable efforts
starting with WW2. During the war, Eli Lilly
would partner with the American Red Cross to
process plasma for wounded soldiers. And by the
end of the war, they would process over 2 milllion
pints of blood which was about 20% of all of the
plasma that was processed in the United States.
But their contribution to WW2 was nothing in
comparison to their contribution Polio. If you
paid attention in history class, the name Jonas
Salk may ring a bell. Salk is the legend that
created the Polio vaccine. But not only did he
create the vaccine, but he also actively chose
to not patent it so that it could reach as
many people as possible. For obvious reasons,
Salk is often described as a hero and rightfully
so but he didn’t do it alone. While he had created
the vaccine, it still had to be distributed to
people around world and the first person to step
up to the plate was of course Eli Lilly. But
this was also one of the last universally good
activities that Eli would participate in. Since
then, most of their philanthropic activities
have had an undertone of branding and marketing
which isn’t the worst thing but also not ideal.
But what has really given Eli a bad rep
since then is their medications themselves.
THE DARK SIDE:
One of Eli’s first controversial
medications was Darvon which came out in the
late 1950s. The medication was advertised as
a mild pain killer which it was not very effective
at but what it was effective at was getting people
addicted. And this is not too surprising when you
consider that it falls into the Opioid category.
By the early 1970s, these dangerous side effects
were starting to become clear and non profits like
Public Citizen were started to advocate for a ban.
Eli Lilly would of course try to defend Darvon
claiming that it was safer and less addictive than
morphine. But the allegations claimed that Darvon
was actually even less effective than Aspirin
in terms of pain relief but even more effective
than the white stuff in terms of killing people.
Despite this, it wasn’t till 2010 that the FDA
would finally ban Darvon meaning that Eli Lilly
was able to profit off of Darvon for decades.
At least, Darvon was just addictive, some of Eli’s
other medications were straight up harmful like
an antibiotic called Erythromycin. In the 1970s,
evidence emerged that this antibiotic was toxic
for the liver often resulting in Jaundice. The
FDA would initially ask Eli to discontinue the
product but after another review at Eli’s request,
the FDA would somehow change the mind. Another
Eli medication that was straight up deadly was the
synthetic estrogen DES. Apparently, the medication
was supposed to prevent miscarriages but it
actually just led to women developing cancer.
Worse, it led to their daughters developing cancer
as well. A couple of class action lawsuits were
filed against Eli but none of these really went
anywhere as Eli would just pay these people off
by settling outside of court. You would think that
Eli would be more careful after these lawsuits but
they would actually become more risk on with
an arthritis medication called Oraflex. In the
early 1980s, dozens of people taking Oraflex would
end up dying due to liver and kidney failure. Any
moral pharmaceutical company would pause the sale
of Oraflex and conduct more testing or atleast
include a warning label. But, what Eli did was try
to cover up the fact that people were dying from
regulators. And this is not an allegation, this
is actually a fact as Eli would end up pleading
guilty. But, do you know what the fine was for
this heinous crime? A pitiful $25,000. Usually,
we talk about how such fines are nothing in
comparison to what these companies earn. But
$25,000? I mean, that’s literally something that
a lot of everyday people can afford. Diabetes
patients literally have to pay more than this to
Eli for insulin over a 5 year period. So, yeah,
you can take that for what you will. All of this
brings us into Eli’s worst offense which is of
course Prozac. In the late 1980s, Eli Lilly would
launch an anti depressent called Prozac despite
allegedly having evidence that Prozac increased
the likelihood of people self offing. When third
party evidence came out against Prozac, Eli would
launch a full on campaign to defend Prozac. It
appears that Eli was successful at defending
Prozac but that also means that humanity was
unsuccessful at defending our most vulnerable. And
the results speak for themselves. People ending it
all has increased by 50% over the past 20 years
as hundreds millions of people took Prozac.
THE TRUTH ABOUT ELI LILLY:
Since then, Eli Lilly has
battled with hundreds of lawsuits and dozens of
fines. But while this has created some friction
for their business, it has by no means stopped the
damage. None of this is to say that Eli Lilly is
evil just because they put out medications
with side effects. The reality is that no
clinical testing is perfect and some side effects
only show up at scale, so that’s not a problem.
The reason that Eli Lilly is evil is because
they do not respond to this damage. In fact,
they actively try to get away with it. They deny
that their medications are causing the damage,
they inist on keeping their medications
available despite mounting evidence against them,
and they even conceal evidence that makes
their medications look bad. Not to mention,
they also exercise monopolistic control over much
of the pharmaceutical market all for what? Well,
to sell as many medications as possible
and to maximize profits over human lives.
And looking at the numbers, this is one thing that
Eli is extraordinarily good at as they’re headed
towards becoming a fortune 10 company. But, while
they may still have an empire, it doesn’t change
that that empire was built on blood. Did you
know about Prozac or Eli Lilly’s role in all
of this? Comment that down below. Also, drop a
like if you agree that Eli Lilly is a truly evil
company. And of course, consider checking out
our discord community to suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.